if you have an abnormal heart rhythm
your doctor may perform electrical
cardioversion where he or she uses an
electrical shock to restore your normal
heartbeat the heart normally beats in a
regular rhythm at 60 to 100 beats per
minute this steady and coordinated
rhythm allows the heart to effectively
pump blood electrical signals that
travel through the heart control the
heart's rhythm these electrical signals
start in a cluster of cells called the
sinoatrial node or pacemaker the
sinoatrial node or SA node is located in
the wall of the right upper chamber of
the heart called the right atrium when
the electrical signals reach the heart
muscle they cause it to contract and
pump blood an abnormal heart rhythm is
called an arrhythmia
during atrial fibrillation the atria
quiver because of chaotic electrical
signals in the heart resulting in an
abnormally fast or irregular heartbeat
because of the abnormal heartbeat blood
may pool in the atria
which can result in the formation of a
blood clot
blood clot passes into the general
circulation
a stroke
before the procedure you will be
connected to an intravenous line you
will be sedated so you will sleep
through the procedure
EKG electrodes will be placed on your
chest to monitor your heart's electrical
activity once you are sedated special
cardioversion pads or paddles will be
placed on the skin of your chest or your
chest and back these pads or paddles
will deliver electrical shock through
your chest to your heart the shock may
be repeated several times until the
heart resumes its normal rhythm
after your electrical cardioversion you
will be monitored closely in a recovery
room or in the coronary care unit of the
hospital once the sedation wears off and
you are in stable condition you will be
sent home